thank you very much for this invitation
tunity to talk and discuss
cities in the protection of cultural
heritage I have been working for the
last two years and do near cielos and s
but during all my career I have served
in the public sector and I can't avoid
thinking about public policies so please
allow me not to talk exclusively about
our university but give a general view
about heritage education in Chile the
Chilean economy has been growing
enormously in the last 30 years and the
globalization phenomenon has had great
impact the preservation of our heritage
is part of the tension between different
interest in the country's development
compared to 30 years ago when i started
my career and the significance of
heritage was unknown for most people
citizens show now a huge interest in
heritage the day of cultural heritage
has become a celebration throughout
chili and whole families visit monuments
museums and historical centers
communities organism organists organized
themselves claiming for the conservation
of the neighborhoods and politicians
incorporate a concern for heritage
preservation in the speeches committees
are getting increasingly involved some
examples are these the Museum of the
City of Canada a city that is in the
midst of an area of the rhetoric
conflict between the mad butcher and
destination state is helping to
establish bridges between them I had the
honor of inaugurating the murder the
remodeling of its permanent exhibition
which was made in conjunction with the
community the director is am a poet
teacher following their requirements the
selections of objects was their decision
text and labels were written in
collaboration with am a butcher poet
cooking and weaving classes are part of
the activities and some spaces were left
for meetings and traditional games the
National Park Service agreed three years
ago
that the income due to visitors on
Easter Island was to be giving to the
community with the aim to invest in the
preservation of the my studies I hope it
will happen however this growing
interest has not resulted yet in the
systematic support of permanent policies
I dare to say that the main weakness
lies and the field of training training
cultural heritage should involve both
physical preservation and access
policies that balance is not happening
in Chile at the moment we do not have
any training program in conservation of
objects and collections mainly due to
the lack of funding at present there are
five university programs training in the
field of cultural heritage on a graduate
level three are part of schools
architecture and train students in the
management and conservation of built
heritage and urban planning and only two
are related to greater ship and
collections management one of them is
the program of the université de los
andes which focuses primarily on
collections curatorship and management
with the training that minds art history
documentation education marketing and
fundraising we encourage our students to
understand not only the principles
policies and practices of the discipline
but to let management tools useful the
challenge they shall face in
professional practice being aware of the
many social and educational challenges
Chile currently has and the competition
for funding between different sectors
our aim is to develop and teach good
governance principles and Beth best
practices graduates have found work in
museum states agencies culture planning
agencies historic preservation and
universities and many of them have
started their own business and managed
and management of cultural heritage as
for conservation programs we have had
two in Chile but neither of them for
sustainable and they closed
both programs managed to form a good
number of well-trained professionals
however none of them both either able to
consolidate join a teaching program and
could not establish permanent research
activities the we have the ability of
launching a new conservation program in
any University will become a very
difficult task the Heritage sector has
changed its priorities in the last
decade from object restoration to
preventive conservation from physical to
virtual visitors this kind of work does
not need extremely well-trained
conservators but other capacities are
required of course a general no
knowledge of the duration processes but
the good managerial and communication
skills are highly recommendable as
universities we must ask ourselves the
following questions how many
conservatives will the country need in
the future ten universities contribute
with research to get less expensive
conservation practices will museum
libraries and Archives still continuing
hiring specialized conservators and if
they do what kind of training is
suitable for this new scenario thank you
very much